and so without further ado we'll get
right into it so sort of the vertex
elevator pitch is that it's a
lightweight platform for micro services
with what they call polyglot language
support and sort of an actor like
concurrency so it's essentially node
style concurrency you know yo dawg I
hope you like callbacks because I've got
a call back in your call that kind of
style and so the lightweight part of
this has actually been really refreshing
both in my work and that been mentioned
by other people as well it's a it's a
platform that mostly stays out of your
way and we'll see this in some of the
code i'll present later it is geared
towards microservices this isn't
necessarily the platform on which you're
going to host your big database or
something like that instead you'll
probably have a module or some unit of
functionality living in vertex talking
externally to your you're heavier
resources as far as polyglot language
support goes so this is the list of
languages that vertex supports as of
their two dot one release which just
came out i believe it was within the
last month or so and there these are
like I said I think this is the official
list and there's a couple of others
whose names I don't recall that are that
are not included in the official list
but can be added you simply change a
configuration file to pull in an
additional language module and tell
vertex this kind of file is associated
with this language very easy to do so as
I'm JRuby and J my mom yes yes daikon
and jari be and I you'll have to check
out the vertex website for the what
JavaScript runtime they're using I don't
know if the top of my head so alright so
jumping right in its kind of set up some
of the vocabulary and and give an idea
of the different pieces of the vertex
system so ever text instance is you know
when i run a a vertex module or a vertex
and vertical from the command line it's
bringing up a vertex instance so that's
one JDM and then it spins up for each
core it spins up an event loop and when
you launch verticals or launch modules
that contain verticals those versions
get assigned to event loose and so
that's each actually I've got a slide on
verticals coming up next we'll just go
right to that one so a vertical this
lovely misspelling is the sort of
fundamental unit of execution within
vertex so when I'm writing some basic
piece of functionality that's going to
be a vertical it's you can write it as
if it were single threaded but you are
running in an event loop so don't do
something synchronous don't block the
event loop
you block it for everybody that's so any
other verticals that are running on that
event loop are blocked as well if you
really want to do some blocking maybe
some i/o operations or something like
that and this is a tactic a lot of the
like for example the JDBC module that we
use is actually specified you can
specify something to be a work or
vertical so it has its own worker thread
pool so it can do synchronous operations
on a thread pool and not block the main
event loop and so this sort of one of
the sort of big ideas behind vertex or
the maybe should have gone on the
elevator pitch slide is that you can run
multiple instances of the same vertical
and that's sort of how you achieve
scaling I'll talk about a little bit
more about that when we get into the
message bus or the afib bus rather and
see what vertex brings in that regard
but anyway the point is you you write in
verticals with an idea that you may be
running 10 or 20 of them on a vertex
instance at one time or even across the
vertex cluster so oh and I what I didn't
say this beginning but please feel free
to interrupt with questions or whatever
I'm happy to answer whatever I can
alright so vertical is like I said were
the sort of basic unit of functionality
these deployable unit of vertex
functionalities is a called a module and
so that encompasses the individual
verticals so you might have one or more
verticals in a module you might have
none any dependencies so many jars or
anything like that get packaged up in
here as well this is it's just a zip
file and the other important of part of
this is that they're deployed to maven
or bin tray which I actually wasn't
familiar before I started using vertex
but that's a repository for binaries and
so using these modules you can actually
so you could run vertex and then point
it at whatever maven repository you want
and then when you say vertex run this
module you don't have it locally it will
go out and resolve those the coordinates
that are in the vertex module
specification resolve those to make
importance and download that module so
the what I'll show later I've installed
modules to my local main repository so
that when i do when i run them through
verte exits that's where scribing them
from and there's actually an entire sort
of ecosystem around this there's a
vertex module registry and it's
searchable and you can find modules for
pretty much anything maybe not anything
but lots of common functionality is is
out there and then the other thing so
modules are the way that
way back up sorry you're using modules
to start up and configure your
application too so if you have a simple
application that might be one module it
might be a handful of verticals you're
telling that module is contains a
configuration and also uses one of the
verticals to coordinate the deployment
of the other verticals and I don't
actually have an example of that but
it's a common sort of idiomatic vertex
thing to do is to have a very small a
pas file which is the sort of
coordination vertical that lives at the
root level of your module and launches
all of your other verticals and assigns
them bits and pieces of a larger
configuration so let's see all right
something else we get and this is on it
this is a on a per module basis you can
actually cluster vertex like fail to
mention that for the slide but you can
start several vertex instances either on
a single machine or across network it
uses multicast they discover each other
and you can
essentially what that end up doing is
sharing the vertex your biz bus which
I'll talk about again in a second across
all of those vertex instances that are
forming that cluster you can also you
can do high availability so what that
means in the context of vertex is that
you can specify that a module should be
highly available and what that means is
if you bring that module up on one
vertex instance and it it terminates
unclean li for some reason you'll see me
do this with kill dash nine that module
we brought up on another vertex instance
in the cluster automatically the
important thing to note there is that
the vertex allows you to run modules
from a local directory but if that other
vertex instance out there on the network
somewhere it doesn't know where to find
your module it won't be brought up it
doesn't transfer to cross magic than
anything so like I mentioned before
everything that I'm doing is going to my
local main repository to define its
modules does it change no it doesn't do
straight state transfer you can take
advantage of some of our texts shared
like shared data functions too if you
want to persist state so that you can
bring up you know a module that's being
sort of revived and grab whatever shared
state but you have to do that explicitly
that's going to be part of your part of
vertical
and then you can also and so I'm
actually be demoing the high
availability and clustering portion
later the h.a groups is just a way to
specify you can say this this module
belongs to this hive elderly group so it
won't get brought up except for in an
instance that also has the modules that
make up that I velboa group so if you
have modules that rely on each other
I'll talk a little bit in a little bit
just about the constraints around shared
data one of the biggest ones is that
that only works across an instance right
now I'm usin foreclosure so so that
actually that's sort of that slightly
negates what I told you but they're
planning to support that cluster wide so
all right
alright the eventbus I've mentioned it a
few times this is just a shared
communications fabric so it's the
messages that you pass across the
eventbus are transient there's no dirt
they're not durable at all they you can
use some set of basic primitives and but
primarily complex lectures are encoded
in JSON that's sort of a lingua franca
across all of the vertex language
modules so too to receive messages you
register a message handler on an address
an address on the event bus is just a
string so you can do whatever kind of
name spacing or enforce whatever
convention you want to but it's just a
string to send a message you just event
bus send the address and the message in
the case of closure it will
automatically convert closure date
closure data structures to JSON and vice
versa when receiving messages although
there's actually a bug in the D
serialization that's going to be fixed
in the next release there's a couple
different topologies available so
there's there's a point to point so
that's essentially sending a message on
the event bus to an address and if there
are if there's one hand or register
on the address that handler will receive
the message if there are multiple
handlers registered on that address only
one of them will receive the message and
according to the documentation that that
occurs in kind of a round-robin style I
don't know if it's if we want to
consider that to be load balancing but
that's just that's the semantics of that
messaging topology and then the other
one we're all familiar with is uh pub
sub so you publish a message to an
address and all registered handlers of
that address will receive the message
and then there's the another common
pattern is this request response so I
send to an address a receiver receives
that message then using that message as
the context can reply that message and
you can keep building that that
conversation as deep as you want to go
go ahead
I believe it's built on hazel past so
and actually part of Toby's talk you
mentioned that that is modular enough
where you could potentially switch that
out with some other some other messaging
solution or a messaging fabric you
wanted to I haven't explored that at all
all right
and so this is the shared data that i
mentioned earlier it's very simple at
this point and although their plans are
to make this work across a cluster
across a network at right now it's
suddenly data is only shared amongst the
verticals and the module is running on a
single vertex instance and so you just
have maps and sets available to you and
their art there's there's pretty much
nothing else and I actually I will not
be demoing the shared data at all
alright and then this is going to recap
a little bit and just sort of give an
idea of the other things that are
available in the vertex core API so we
talked about the event bus and shared
data they've got a full suite of network
servers and clients and they're wrapping
a lot of Nettie as in Toby's talk he's
sort of called out one of the advantages
vertex is it hides some the complexity
of Nettie and one of its disadvantages
is also that it hides some of the
complexity of Nettie but and so the demo
I'll show later is actually going to
we'll see HTTP and some sock j/s so
there's also there's a few other things
timers so you can tell a vertex I want
to the other question sorry so you can
tell vertex I want to run something
either on a delay or periodically there
are sort of lower level buffers in case
you want to do some streaming operations
and things like that there there's both
synchronous and asynchronous access to
the local file system and and then
there's mother there's some other API
around configuration what's
alright here's why why we're here right
so closure support it was made official
in the vertex 2.1 release that was that
just came out about a month ago the
actual closure language module the
oldest git commit in that repository is
about a year old like I mentioned
already Toby Crawley who works at a blue
key works at Red Hat is the sort of
primary author and then there's a few
other contributors there's some tooling
and libraries that are that are already
available in varying states of
usefulness completeness and reliability
i'll be using well actually I don't know
that all demo mine vertex but that's
what i've been using while I've been
developing the sample application for
tonight that's just a line of gin plugin
that allows you to easily pull together
all of your dependencies are specified
in your project clj it'll build modules
for you it'll actually let you run
vertex if composes a sort of a rapper
vertical to launch everything so it's
nice although it's not is that those are
the two sort of things that it does
right now and there's a lot more a lot
more there so hopefully we'll see that
improved and then there's actually also
a ring the ring vertex adapter which
lets you essentially wrap the vertex
HTTP server in ring and then you can go
from there and use composure
do all of your sort of normal middleware
and whatever you'd like to do sort of an
enclosure a web stack is available to
you but it does not wrap any of the ring
Aesop libraries I wish it did David was
just telling me that he's working on
some ring async stuff but that's one of
the actual I've got it and my speaker
notes here is that the that essentially
from the point at which you wrap things
in this in this ring vertex adapter
you're now you're now synchronous so and
that's so ring is looking at responses
coming back and as soon as you try to
pass a channeler or something like that
it it blows up yeah
so yeah so that's that's the state of
that something else that was it was a
question mark ? in what September
November adobe stock it's still a
question mark we have this really great
sort of asynchronous application
platform and we've all heard of this
little library called gory sink so
wouldn't it be great if the two could
meet and the answer is and they it's
still not quite there what would be
really nice and the pseudocode that Toby
showed his talk was you call in a bit
less messaging function and you get back
a channel that would be fantastic I and
that doesn't exist yet that work hasn't
been done or it's not it's not on github
for sure I've played around a little bit
with corey sync both in the stuff that
we've done at intent and as long as you
have one instance of your vertical and
depending on where you put your your go
block things things mostly work it's
easy it's very very easy to lose lose
the eventbus message context so that
becomes another thing that you have to
pass around where you didn't before so
I'm not sure yet that I've come across a
use case where Corey sync made things
much more readable or simpler to reason
about so in the end and for this demo
I've sort of I've just sucked it up and
we have callbacks so and I'm more than
happy to show anybody some of those
those Corey sync attempts later all
right so this is actually this is kind
of an overview of the demo I I don't
know if anybody here has ever used any
kind of chat application I figured this
was sudden greenfield development anyway
it's it's it's going to demonstrate
several the features that I've talked
about a vertex and it sort of comes with
four main components and I have source
code for each of these in the slides and
then i'll actually demo the live at so
the core component is just that it's
just launching verticals it's it's the
initialization that's that happens when
the module starts up it goes out and
launches the blogger of the time stamper
and the web vertical the blogger
vertical is just listening for all the
messages and storing them the time
scamper is periodically emitting a
timestamp so I guess you see some chat
programs where ever you know
15 minutes for every hour you get a time
stamp in your in your chat log so that's
what's happening here the web vertical
is serving an HTML and some CSS and
JavaScript and it's also and the
interesting part is it's actually
bridging the event bus through sock jas
to a closure script client-side app so
we're going to see that arm in the web
browser I can actually use the event bus
just like I can on the on the closure
side so anyone you know without further
ado
alright so this is very simply this is a
course so you can see yeah there's not
much to it I'm deploying verticals what
do you do you do notice that when you're
deploying vertically you're not
deploying a namespace or a class name or
anything like that you're actually
telling you where to find the file and
it is so vertex is looking at that
saying that's a clj file I know that I
can run clj files use a V closure
closure language module and so that's
that's what sort of happening in this
deployment
in this case I've told line vertex that
in it is the function and then when it
builds the module it puts a little a
vertical in there that basically it's uh
it's called out as that is the initial
vertical and then it calls the init
method in the namespace that I've told
my vertex about so
so here's the logger and so what what
this is doing and I'll tell you later
why I split this into two parts so that
the top is the sort of main logger
namespace and the bottom is the
implementation and so at the top we can
see here that I'm just registering
message handlers on each of these event
bus addresses so we have the chat
address and the history address and then
skipping down here so the log handler is
registered on the chat address so when
it receives a message it's just going to
add that to an atom so it's maintaining
a list of messages in the application
and I'm not too worried about exceeding
the the memory limits of the machine
during this demo but of course you might
want to try something different when you
push this to production and then the
history handler is actually so its
register on the history endpoint and
what that's doing is when a request
comes in on that on that address it's
grabbing the last in items from the
history Adam and so we'll see how that's
used in the client-side application in a
minute
there's the time Stamper so this is
simply once a minute is just publishing
on the chat channel so this is that pub
cell that we talked about a message from
user time stamp with the current date
and then last but not least this is the
the web vertical so we're doing we're
serving files and starting a web server
and then the for a more interesting part
is here actually before I get to that I
will say this over text has a pre
full-featured HTTP application API
available to you so it can do in
addition to just serving HTTP you can do
routing it has some facilities in here
so you can see I've just said send file
use a string as a file name so it's
there's a lot there you don't
necessarily have to avoid it for this
kind of application if you you know if
you can't use ring you can still use
this and it's not too bad but so like I
said the more interesting part is down
here this is actually where we're
bridging the event bus through soft jas
to the browser and so this is just
setting up that bridge and then so this
prefix is telling it this is the path on
which we're we're we're bridging the
event bus on our HTTP server and then
these two sets of these two collections
of maps right here this is how you
secure the event bus from your client so
here you can specify communications from
the client through to the eventbus are
only allowed on these two channels
and then here you can specify it it
outgoing so from the event but back to
the client can only come on those two I
set channels I meant I meant addresses
only on those two addresses and there's
some further capability there which I
don't have here the app is really isn't
complex enough to need it but you can
specify a dress regular expressions that
have to match and you can also although
it's a little basic at this point you
can specify the exact format of the
messages that are allowed to pass as
well so for instance maybe you have
something that it can execute some
predefined queries on endpoints you can
specify each of those messages and that
message doesn't match exactly it won't
get passed through from the client back
to the event bus so yeah any questions
before I launch into the demo no all
right
all right so yeah please so when you
have the
surgeons for which addresses their boots
are also a way to like at runtime say
and also now you can do this or no
longer to this pattern or column
labelling when you created the bridge
I'm not sure actually that's a good
question I don't know other questions
all right
oh that's incredibly funny
all right everybody see this yeah okay
all right so I've got two modules
actually so this application what I just
showed you the code that you saw was one
module more or less and then I've
actually got a second module to
demonstrate some failover the actual
code behind that isn't quite as
interesting so I'm going to go ahead and
launch if I'm saying vertex run mod I've
given it these are the vertex
coordinates so it's essentially group ID
application ID version separated by till
days and then this flag on the end this
dash H a stands for high availability
and that also implies the cluster flag
so I'm going to launch this hopefully it
will work
alright so i have now that vertical are
sorry that module is running so i'm
going to go i'm going to fumble around
here first i am ok
all right everybody basically see this
so sorry is that better or worse all
right so I have a box down here I can
just type in my handle and I can put
messages I don't leave that bus they
show up here that's not that interesting
because I could be faking it so let's
pull up another web browser and all
right so there's unattached to be a bit
bus i got the time stamps coming in
you'll notice when I loaded the second
web browser that it actually populated
some history that's that history command
so the client actually sent a message to
the history in endpoint and said give me
ask for five elements that only had one
available and so that's this is a very
simple demonstration of bridging that
event bus to the client so
let's start another vertical or another
module five so this is this is another
module and all of this code and
everything is available and the script
for doing all of this is available on in
github right now so you guys can check
it out after the f what we're done so
this is the vertex chat robot so I'm
watching I'm watching that with the same
module specifier but our vertex chat
robot notice I also specify three
instances and i also have specified high
availability so let's launch this and
for some reason that occasionally
happens and it didn't happen at that
time yeah I'm not sure yeah so anyway
see here we've got actually some
initialization messages Robo one two and
three and I that code is actually using
some using a capability that we have in
that we love enclosure right is the
ability to do concurrent access to you
know things like atoms so it's actually
using an atom because those three
instances of the vertical were launched
in the same vertex instance they're
actually using the same closure runtime
which is really nice and so we can use
an atom just in the way that we we would
expect to and increment it and use that
to name our robots so let's
double check that
there are some robots that have joined
yeah
and those are my lame attempt set at
making random emoticons so that's that's
not work there we go ok so this is this
is pretty cheesy let's see something
when we're interesting let's kill that
I'm going to kill the robot module
from orbit the only way be sure all
right so that one's dead I've killed
that that vertex instance and I can see
over here that that completely blew up
awesome all right um
ok end of demo that's yeah I i apologize
that that didn't work that worked great
when i went through all this before hand
so what we would have seen is that after
killing that robot vertex instance those
three robots would have started up on
the first vertex instance and we would
have still been able to interact with
them in the chat room but i'm not gonna
I'm not going to waste everybody's time
debugging what might have changed at the
last second so what's that I actually
tested it without a Wi-Fi connection
thinking that that would that would be
the case but anyway that's what would
have happened and I encourage you all to
play with it and send in your PRS to fix
whatever whatever I broke those lil
Reese says there's a far so you're not
sharing the closure runtime or they're
not the initializing the right order it
should be tell you what let's um let's
what let's play that game real quick and
see and just bring up one instance
because I would like to demonstrate
failover
all right we've got those let's double
check that we can
alright that's working let's see we have
we've got we've got one robot yeah
that's a scalp
alright and let's try to kill this guy
alright
so we've killed in hey there we go ya
got so we solve it node that node failed
and we can see that this vertex instance
brought up that that module so high
availability demo thank you for the
suggestion yeah alright so and yeah
let's send another message to the the
robot yeah and Robo one is back in
business so alright so that's that's the
extent of the demo I'm going to move on
to talk about testing less anybody has
any other questions about this or I
don't I didn't actually put up a slide
of my awful awful closure script the
only the only vertex really the things
that's doing is is publishing on the
event bus and receiving messages from
the event bus and it looks exactly the
same as the closure verticals that we've
already seen and the rest of it is me
trying to use reagent and and kind of
stumbling around badly so you guys can
check that out in the github repo
alright
let's go back to
yes
alright testing this is this was a
notable omission from the closure cons
presentation but there is some some
reasonable support for doing that doing
testing in sort of a vertex style so
they vertex test tools namespace
provides this as embedded potion I
believe and what that's essentially
doing is wrapping wrapping your test in
this case because I'm using it as a
fixture using a closure test it's
wrapping this in an embedded vertex
instance and allowing you to do sort of
the things you expect be able to do like
register handlers send messages and then
you can also when you call this vertex
test tools Test complete that's
essentially telling that embedded vertex
instance that I'm done here are some
some things I'm going to assert about
the test just those are just normal
normal closure test is there shut the
embedded vertex down so this actually
this works pretty well I can run it from
line test now part of the reason that I
noticed before I split up the logger
into kind of the namespace that was
registering event handler or the bus
handlers and and then there was the
implementation namespace you get into
situation where when you require a file
that are a namespace that's that's in at
its root level it's trying to register
message handlers or something like that
and it doesn't have a vertex instance
already available to it that blows up
completely so it just becomes convenient
to split things up like this when you're
launching things through a vertex
instance that it's starting the vertical
but it's already created a sort of all
the necessary
for structure for that to come up
without me without blowing up completely
so yeah so that's that's testing and
let's see I the other thing I was just
going to mention I something I
discovered in trying to put together
some of these tests is that there's
actually a bug in the current version of
modeling closure that doesn't allow you
to run more than one test using the test
tools as embedded it doesn't reset at
state in the way that it needs to but if
it's for that is also coming in the next
release
alright and that's actually that's about
it here all the resources that I've
mentioned so there's the vertex homepage
they have tons of documentation it's
actually really well put together
there's both a sort of getting started
manual there's a a what is a module and
and how to how to run vertex and and all
the various sort of things you can do
and then there's actually a language
specific very very thorough manual for
each of the officially supported
languages so it's actually it's really
good especially for a framework that's
as young as it is it's clear that they
put an emphasis on documentation which
is really refreshing and then there's a
link also to Toby Crowley's talk from
the conch I highly recommend watching
that we cover a lot of the same things
but he says it all with a really lovely
like North Carolina accent and so then
there's the line vertex and ring vertex
adapter links to github i'm actually i'm
not sure if anybody is currently
maintaining line vertex I know Toby has
made a few commits and I actually I
think that i put together today was done
on a version that I had to modify to
actually support the latest version of
vertex so they didn't have to
manually pull in a closure line module
things like that and then there's a link
to these slides and all the demo code is
out there on github so any any questions
or comments
just barely
how does one define invertible
asian place for it what
um so
you think about a vertical as sort of
the core the court unit of vertex right
and so one of the first things you you
can specify how many instances of that
you run so you have some piece of
functionality or some some sort of
logical break out of your code you want
to be able to scale that horizontally
that sounds like a vertical right it's
other than that I think the sky is
pretty much the limit I mean we're
running verticals in another project
that are registered on multiple handlers
not just not just a few anything that
you want to be able to startup and
shutdown independently so if you have if
you want to reinitialize a vertical that
reinitialize some some piece of your
of your application that's a good
candidate for vertical as well so
recognitions for splitting an address
finish charting some things so if you
want to start up some n number of
instances that's supported portion of
your user base so you they don't at the
moment that's something you have to
either right into your app or there's
actually a project out there called
vertigo which I will modify this and put
a link to that on in the presentation
they purport to do some of those things
I'm not sure if address space sharding
is necessarily one of them but they do a
lot of be kind of the grunt work of
managing a distributed application in a
sensible way on top of vertex so you can
still you know do things like use the
event bus at that fundamental level but
as far as saying oh I want ten verticals
10 of these verticals were running this
instance and 11 of these other verticals
running over here some of them are high
availability and some of them or not I
think it's trying to handle a lot of
that for you just let you sort of
specify the behavior of the cluster you
want
unfortunately I hadn't played with it at
all but its own person yeah definitely
you so they're actually there's a
capability that I did demonstrate but
when you are doing the point-to-point
messaging you can specify bird fly
handlers and timeouts and error handlers
so in that case you actually will get an
indication if your message was not
delivered you know if you were sending
to address where nobody's listening if
you were expecting a reply and none came
within the timeout period on you're
going to notification of that the pub
sub I actually don't believe you'll get
any I think you can even publish
messages to whatever addresses you want
and nobody's listening you'll never know
so
question editor question yeah please
stop
talk a little bit about how you
described it as kind of an actor model
is that carry forward to this error
handling you know
vertical the supervisor
if you would like to have verticals that
supervised other verticals you can
definitely write it that way and
something so one of the patterns I've
used is in the in actually in am
semi-related ways to have vertical
watching a shared data structure for
errors and shutting down other verticals
but you you have to design it that way
there's nothing there's nothing both in
like that no it's the interface you have
two things like like the bus errors are
air handlers on a bit bus functions that
you're calling so is that sort of answer
your question or
possible in a standard way I'm like is
there
just receive
right so there's nothing built in I know
that Toby and the a mutant group have
done some work doing a JMS to of it but
event bus bridge I haven't explored that
at all but I know it's out there and
then aside from that I think that's
that's a case of roll-your-own is it is
just JSON so you've easily just exposed
and point to take case on it and check
it on the event bus yeah obviously it's
actually on application
surround the most of the processes in
your decades of experience those
peasants wait wait would you just use
multiple processes for the baby multiple
instances of the same one all just right
so something there are some things that
I haven't necessarily enjoyed about
about vertex but I will say that the
simplicity of messaging is I was I was
surprising rien and really refreshed
that it's that it's so easy to to set up
communication between pieces of your
code and the sort of multicast discovery
of and setting a little cluster across a
network it just works so my argument is
that my argument for choosing vertex is
probably that if you want something that
you can spin up very quickly and that's
it's a fantastic choice if you're
looking for something that's and you're
very very concerned about performance or
something like that and you might have
to explore what vertex offers in this in
those areas
and and then decide I know that what's
this odd that the fellow who does that
call me maybe yes all i can think of his
animated barbie dolls yeah but so i know
i know that somebody's done to jettison
test hazel cast which underlies a lot of
vertex i only know that because I saw
the placeholder for the results I didn't
actually see the results so that's that
forms another question I like that might
inform decisions about when to use for a
Texan or not so
I'm circumcision
I don't know I was trying to find out
with the question I asked first year
weird I know what intent we're using it
but not it's not client-facing it's for
some internal tools and it's very called
very wroth right now do you think it's
ready
I
that's probably the answer did you know
CeCe me waffling a little bit i think
the at least my experience with the
closure language module is that it's it
feels like maybe ninety eight percent
there so I think I mean Toby and those
guys have done a great job getting it to
the the point is that and it's the API
that they're they're wrapping is
full-featured with respect to the
residents of the sort of vertex
ecosystem but I haven't gotten the
impression that there's a lot of people
doing especially not doing a closure on
vertex and production just based on the
experiences that I had I don't know
actually you know I would love to know
and I don't know if but Toby ask that
question at the conch and got a similar
like everybody's hands behind her back
but nobody the closure meet up in New
York and she's needed in production
except for
I don't believe there are I think
there's a hazel cast monitoring or at
least a couple of hazel cast monitoring
tools that you might be able to hook in
but yeah I'm not aware of any although i
would encourage if you have questions
about specific like functionality or
capabilities check out the the module
repository and just do a search because
there's there might be something out
there that i haven't tried to use yet
but it does exist so any other questions
all right well it's been a pleasure
thanks for